à le retrouver
je
m
mick harvey
le keeper du mois
elle ne doute pas
parce que
est ce que dans vos inspirations
musicales justement la nature les
insectes les animaux peut avoir une part
way sûrement je sais pas si j'ai
travaillé j'ai écrit une chanson à
propos d'un chien et mirza fait mais
même ça va pas mal marqué les jambes il
ya une quinzaine d'années de ça et
continuent à me demander si j'ai
retrouvé mon chien quand il parle dans
la rue c'est pas une mise à mal
pop
j'avais pas vu mirza j'ai fait un
morceau il ya deux ans de ça un morceau
que j'ai intitulé blues des chiens et
les pas du tout question de chiens à
l'intérieur mais c'était une chanson
d'amour assez triste et assez dérisoire
et la cij avait fait rentrer alors les
coeurs des chiens parce que mes chiens
chante chante très bien elle surtout
elle chante très bien alors j'ai appelé
le blues des chiens et on entend les
chiens chanter effectivement là
malheureusement je crois qu'on ne pourra
pas entendre vania chanter parce que
c'est une un rapport très intime
well charles très bien mais quand je
suis seul avec elle je lui fais des
petits bruits bizarres bon genre du
bruit que font les dindons vous savez
des choses comme
vous êtes trop nombreux bugs et c'est un
marché que quand même temps c'est pas
qu'elle aurait encore 10 au général
alors quand je suis seul à savoir sur
les grands événements comme ça et elle a
l'air très contente de le faire
d'ailleurs elle remue la q1 c'est assez
marrant j'ai pas réussi à comprendre
exactement qu'est ce que qu'est ce qui
se passe dans sa tête afin de placer le
baron de la serpillière savez mon perso
ça va ça beaucoup sur le bouton et uc
dont nathalie simon garçons on tient bon
père c'est lui le chef un chef des
chiens c'est lui le voit c'est la
famille complète là c'était bien pour ce
qui est des chiens
donc le chat encore je pas où il est
mais il doit être un peu c'est quand
même plus sauvage matraqués par
l'agitation le monde des lumières ici
j'ai deux mâles et une femelle donc en
tant que chien et sa part une véritable
société
la femelle très casanière
astellas maison restée avec moi se met
près du feu se coucher sur quelque chose
de confortable c'est par contre les deux
mâles y en a un qui est nettement
dominant l autre qui suit valentin le
chien d'aidé enfin les cousins les
chiens des pyrénées vraiment très fort
comme caractère enfin il se laisse pas
marcher sur les sur les pieds ça et rien
à faire même pas par moi enfin je peux
pas ne peut pas avoir le dernier mot
avec lui a rien à faire c'est toujours
lui qui a le dernier mot
notre infections se partagent quand même
y'a pas de préférer n'a pas dit où
j'adore tous mais tous les animaux j'ai
adoré et je passe autant de temps avec
eux pas de problème par contre l'afghan
qui est complètement dans la lune c'est
penser à tournesol de vos professeurs
nimbus voiliers de ce genre est toujours
dans la lune comme ça il fait des
bêtises d'ailleurs mais pape pas parce
que il a décidé de faire des bêtises
parce qu'ils n'y pensent pas simplement
et les chats dits nous lancer vraiment
spécial c'est autre chose c'est quoi
aller chasser génial des gens
connaissent pas les chiens y croise
celle d'un animal à différents qui ne
s'attache pas aux personnes peuvent
avoir du tout le chan animal très très
gentil très affectueuse très intelligent
et très amusante et sont en train très
bien avec d'autres espèces d'animaux et
avec les enfants aussi alors avec mon
fils qu'à cinq ans le chat joue pendant
des heures les heures restent ensemble
avec les chiens j'aime beaucoup les
chats
pas
ap
le chien
yam
seul
voile sur vous
il ne ment
on dirait
reçus
le temps
ici la patte arrière pays complètement
ouvert il n'y a pas de clôtures aérien
et c'est trés désert et ses chiens sont
en liberté totale
les matins quand on le leur ou la porte
ils vont se promener ils vont faire une
balade d'une heure une heure et demie
comme ça ils vont même à 10 20 km le
facteur nous raconte qu'il les rencontre
à 20 kilomètres d'ici sinon puis
reviennent j'allais un peu il certaines
inquiétudes avec les cultivateurs des
environs j'ai peur qu'ils se plaignent
ne pas du tout se passe très bien au
contraire il les aime bien la première
balade qu'ils ont fait c'était très
drôle y avait un match de football au
stade de saint cyprien et ils sont
arrivés dans le stade tous les trois et
ils sont allés voir le match de football
ils ont sans rentrer sur le terrain
j'ai l'intention d'essayer de nous
sortir du show business je continuerai
toujours à faire de la musique parce que
c'est ma passion
mais j'ai envie de faire de la musique
pour moi tout seul pour mes amis j'ai
pas envie d'essayer sur une vedette
vraiment pas envie alors l'endroit où je
suis tout à l'endroit merveilleusement
beau la terre très très belle mais c'est
une terre de parisiens un sommet de
collines dans le fond des vallées
l'intérêt bonne on peut faire des
céréales toutes sortes de cultures sur
le sommet des collines c'est du causse
ne pas faire pousser grand chose peut
faire de l'élevage sur tout et j'ai
l'intention d'essayer de monter un petit
élevage de chevaux rustique ici et puis
des moutons également alors ce poney
c'est la première étape si vous voulez
dans ce futur élevage de chevaux
j'espère avoir ici
courtoise et enfin les carottes pourquoi
battus
bongrain
qu'est ce qu'il ya de fascinant dans les
animaux finalement je suis pas qu'on
peut les aimer sans arrière pensée
finalement les seuls moments dans
lesquels je suis totalement heureuse
sans arrière pensée c'est quand je joue
avec mes animaux quand je suis avec eux
après midi difficile
je m'emploie les camps ce qui vous
concerne c' est au milieu de ses champs
de ce cause de ces animaux que vous
retrouvez ou que vous trouver l'harmonie
oui je sais mais côté de ma femme de mon
fils je vais en avoir un deuxième coup
une deuxième très bientôt
d'ailleurs je pense que quand l'émission
passera il sera déjà la nouvelle sera
dévoilée j'ai trouver l'harmonie j'ai
trouvé un coin de paradis
je dois dire que je pense que j'ai
beaucoup de chance pour ça et je pense
aussi que la vie dans les villes ça me
ça m'angoisse mines une boule d'angoissé
en verre dans l'estomac
je suis pas très bien comment ça va se
terminer tout ça mais j'ai pas envie de
me d'y être j'ai envie d'essayer de
vivre les quelques instants il nous
reste à vivre comme ça au milieu des
animaux dénaturés puis espérant que les
enfants dont
on dirait le sud
deux tendus
autant
et la vie sûrement
jamais
je ne m'en étais